[Music]
just recording pending
okay
uh
without further ado justin you have the
floor
okay thank you for the introduction and
thank you all for coming to my talk
today so i'll be talking about my
project
on developing a brain computer interface
based on visual imagery that i worked on
this summer with my mentor yvonne and
the rest of the bci and audio and
acoustic research teams here at
microsoft
so first off starting a little bit of
background into this research area and
i'd like to ask the question first of
what exactly is a brain computer
interface
in its simplest terms a bci is a
technology to facilitate communication
between the brain and an external device
and importantly this communication does
not depend on any inputs from peripheral
nerves or muscles it's just a direct
communication between the brain and the
device
so a basic framework of this experiment
i might have a person engaged in some
sort of task where they're you know
maybe imagining interacting with some
object on a computer screen
first off you're acquiring their neural
data that data is being processed and
then transmitted over for classification
and translating that code from like a
neural stimulus to a
control code to control something on the
device
so the first step in any bci is
determining how exactly you're going to
measure the neural signal and there's a
few different methods each with their
own pros and cons but one major
consideration is
the spatiotemporal resolutions of each
of these devices
so i'll go through a few of them
starting off with
eeg or electroencephalography
so eeg is like electrodes placed along
the surface of the scalp that can pick
up the small electrical potentials that
occurs when neurons fire
so eg is perhaps the most common
most well used
device are for bci applications
because of its you know relatively
inexpensive
starting cost it's pretty portable like
you can have just a cap that you slide
on easily or electrodes embedded into
some other device like headphones
something like that
it's
got a pretty high temporal resolution
but it has the low spatial resolution so
because you're trying to you know record
the signals through the skull through
the scalp it could be a little bit
difficult to localize where exactly
those brain signals are coming from
so next up in the non-invasive side is
fmri so
this would be functional magnetic
resonance imaging
this is actually what i'm using in my
phd research right now so fmri has a
much higher spatial resolution than eeg
you can get like small like almost
millimeter size
called voxels or brain area which might
have you know a few thousand neurons in
there so it's better spatial resolution
but it has a very low temporal
resolution
so you're only able to capture an image
like every second or two
another issue with fmri is it has a
pretty um pretty big delay because it's
an indirect measure of brain activity so
like with eeg you're measuring the like
electrical potentials of the neurons
directly but with the fmri you're
actually
measuring changes in oxygenated blood
flow into an area of the brain so the
idea here is that
once a region of the brain becomes
activated the body has to feed that area
with additional oxygenated blood so fmri
is actually measuring that increased
blood flow in an area sort of as a proxy
for brain activity
so because of this you have to deal with
an issue known as the hemodynamic delay
which it takes about like four to six
seconds for you to be able to determine
that you know blood flow is increased in
that area so it can be a little bit
difficult timing like when an action
corresponds to an activity in the brain
so moving on to the more invasive
techniques uh one common one is
electrocorticography or ecog
so this is pretty similar to eeg and
that it uses electrodes except now
they're placed along the surface of the
brain
so this has a much higher spatial
resolution and still taking advantage of
the high temporal resolution of eeg
however of course it does require an
invasive surgery which has its own
inherent risk with like infection things
like that and also these electrodes
can't be left in for a very long period
of time because you know over time as
the body's
reacting to this foreign object in the
brain you might have like scar tissue
build up things like that that can cause
the signals to degrade over time
even farther in the invasive side
there's like local field potentials or
spiked electrodes
these would be electrodes placed into
the cortex that could read
like a single neuron or like clusters of
neurons so it has a very high spatial
and temporal resolution however once
again it requires invasive surgery the
signals can degrade over time it's got a
high cost
and a higher power consumption and
latency issues
so next i'd like to talk about some of
the common bci paradigms used in vci
applications
so these paradigms can fall really into
two different camps of evoked potentials
and non-evoked potentials
so an evoked potential would be you know
providing a participant with some sort
of external stimulus and you're
measuring
the brain's response to that stimulus
where a non-evoked potential would be
you know participants engaged in some
sort of imagery so like an endogenous
stimulus and you're just measuring their
brain activity during that imagination
so any evoked potential possibly the
most well-studied and well-known
paradigm is the visual p300
so this is a common event-related
potential that appears as a reaction to
a presented stimulus
so one application of this that you
might have seen before is the p300
speller
so how these devices work is you would
have a subject be able to spell out like
a word or a phrase just by looking at
one of the letters at a time on this
this keyboard
so the different rows and the different
columns are going to be highlighted at
different times and based on what the
participant is looking at and the
changing intensity levels of that that
letter flickering on and off you can
judge you know when the letter
highlights and when the erp response
happens in the brain which letter that
they're looking at
another kind of similar technique is the
steady state visual evoked potential
so
how this would kind of look like is a
person would be presented with this
uh array of flashing targets or like
flashing leds each of these targets will
be flashing at a different frequency
and based on what which target that
they're looking at you can match the
frequency components in their eeg to the
flickering frequency of the target and
identify which one they're attending to
some less studied evoked potentials it
could be like you know measuring a
person's response to an auditory stimuli
or to like a somatosensory or a tactile
stimulation
and then moving on to the more like
non-evoked side of things um
so this would be you know mostly imagery
based paradigms and by far the most
studied one is motor imagery paradigms
so for example of a motor imagery
paradigm like sensory motor rhythms this
could be the imagined movements of large
body parts so for example you might be
imagining opening and closing your right
versus your left hand
there's also imagined body kinematics
which is like the imagined movement of a
single body part in a multi-dimensional
space so this is actually a technique
that i use quite a bit in some of my
past research so an application of this
might be like if you're trying to have a
bci to control a computer cursor like on
a screen you can have a participant
imagine they're moving their right hand
as if they're using a computer mouse to
control the movement directions
some less studied non-evoked potentials
could be like visual imagery so this
would be like a conceptual
reconstruction of a perceptual
experience so like directly imagining an
object that you're trying to interact
with
there's like speech imagery which is
like the imagery of speech production
and there's different categories of
mental effort so this could be things
like you know imagining rotating an
object in a three-dimensional space or
mentally performing math calculations
something like that
so to give a little bit of background
into this project that i was working on
this summer
my main goal was to create a bci using
some kind of nano vote potential and we
wanted to kind of steer clear of motor
imagery so for that reason
i selected visual imagery as the
paradigm that i was going to use
throughout my experiment
and one reason for this is you know
we wanted to do something a little bit
different that hasn't been studied as
much and also visual imagery
provides like a more intuitive control
for bci so say for example
you want a vci to control different
applications in your house like maybe
turning a lamp on or off
with visual imagery you can imagine just
that lamp directly and interact with it
whereas with something like motor
imagery you'd have to remember a map
between your right hand might interact
with that lamp
so next i'd like to just give a little
bit of background into some research in
the visual imagery
bci field
so one study by natalia cosmena from
2018 in this experiment
she was trying to perform classification
of visual observation and visual imagery
periods between two object classes of
either a flower or a hammer so you can
see her task stimulus down here
the participants would first be shown
like a image queue of say like in this
case the hammer it'll would appear on
screen for four seconds and they'd just
be asked to you know attend to that
stimulus
and then it would disappear for four
seconds and that would be like an
imagery period where they tried to you
know imagine the stimulus that they just
saw and then there would be a rest
period
so for her results particularly for like
the observation periods when the
picture was actually on screen you know
she had decent classification accuracy
however when
the image was taken away and the
participants were asked to just imagine
it and she's only able to find around 52
decoding accuracy so right around chance
level
another study by leodoll in 2019 and
repeated in 2020
in this study they were trying to
perform classification of visual and
speech imagery
and they had 13 classes of like common
words for patient communication so these
could be things like um bathroom water
ambulance or more abstract concepts like
help or yes
so for the visual imagery classifier
when they first did this in 2019
they were able to get around like 27
accuracy which doesn't sound great but
with 13 classes and chance level being
around 8 like there's still something
there you're able to
classify between the categories and then
when they repeated this a year later
with a larger cohort of participants and
some different processing techniques
they will do increase this
classification pretty remarkably up to
around 40
percent so the next thing i'd like to
talk a little bit about is some of the
pre-processing steps that you would go
through with working in a eeg bci
so starting out you know you have this
steady stream of raw eeg data come in
one of the first things that you might
do is perform a channel selection so
perhaps at the beginning of a study you
might work with like all the channels in
the cap but sometimes depending on what
the task that you're doing it might be
beneficial to narrow down those channels
to a particular region of interest so
for example if you're doing a murder
task where you have your participants
moving their right versus their left
hand
you might be interested more in like
those c electrodes directly over the
left and right primary motor cortex
or if they're performing like a visual
task you might be more interested in the
o electrodes on the back of the head
directly over the visual cortex
next step you would probably do is apply
a filter to the data usually at this
stage it would mostly be like
eliminating any low or high frequency
noise from the signal that you're not
really interested in
so eeg is usually grouped together in
these bands of brain activity each of
these bands kind of correspond to a
particular state of the brain so for
example like delta waves are usually
seen in like a deep sleep like mu and
beta waves are seen during like motor
movements and executions and imagery
alpha waves usually carry information
about like subjects attention so if
you're trying to see like if they're
attending to a task like alpha ways
usually carry that
as an example
some other filters that you might apply
is just to remove noise like power line
noise
another step that you might want to take
is perform some sort of artifact removal
so eeg can be pretty prone to artifacts
from like motion like eye movement
from like eye blinking or muscle
movement from things like chewing
so the picture up above kind of
demonstrates what an eye blink would
look like
particularly on those frontal channels
if you're doing any sort of analysis
that
is taking advantage of those frontal
channels it might be beneficial to
remove those eye blinks
also be a good idea to epoc the data so
this would be like dividing the data
into smaller windows so this would kind
of depend on you know like the task
period if you want to
divide the data into like when the task
starts and when it ends or maybe even
break that into like smaller categories
that you can process your data and
classify it based off of
and then finally would be like feature
extraction so where you would extract
the time or frequency components from
the signal that you'd like to use as
features during your classification so
like for example maybe before you
started with a broad filter of eeg like
filtering from like 1 to 50 hertz but
now you want to narrow it down to just
use like the alpha band of activity for
feature selection so you might use like
a fft to pull out just that like 8 to 15
hertz range
so next i'll talk a little bit about my
experimental methods and the protocol
that i used here
so the objective of my project was to
create a brain computer interface using
a visual imagery control paradigm and
the recording device that i used for
this experiment was the brain products
acticap express twist
so this cap featured 32 channels of dry
electrodes
with a 500 hertz sample rate
so usually with eeg applications you'd
use like a wet electrode system so this
would have a small amount of
conductive gel placed underneath each
electrode to improve the signal quality
of it
so unfortunately with the dry electrodes
you know due to me having to work at
home alone it's a lot easier to put on a
dry electric cap however they are a
little bit more prone to noise and
you're a little bit limited by how much
data you can collect because if you can
imagine like 32 of these little spikes
pressed against your head it's kind of
difficult to wear that for a prolonged
period of time so i can only maybe wear
it for around like 30 minutes before i
start getting a pretty bad headache
so
for like the overall framework of my
my project here the programs that i use
are open vive lab streaming layer cycle
pi and python
so for this i have like a participant
you know engaged in visual imagery where
they're you know imagining an object
that they're trying to interact with
the visual imagery eeg is recorded
through openvive which transmits the
signal by a lab streaming layer into a
main bci processing script
at the same time i have cycle pi
running the stimulus script it's
controlling you know when the stimulus
is presented for the subject and you
know when the feedback is presented and
it's also sending the stimulus markers
to that main processing script just to
tell it you know when
the
image appears on screen when it goes off
and everything so this main processing
script is just taking in all that data
and labeling it appropriately and
sending it over for online analysis
which carries through all the data
pre-processing the feature extraction
and the classification
and that classification result is sent
back to the psychopay script
to display the feedback
now most of the experiments uh that
you'll see coming up are going to be
like offline analysis so the only
difference here is that we're not
actually giving a feedback to the
psychopay script it's just this main
processing script is saving all the data
for offline analysis
so for the first experiment that i
carried out
really what we wanted to do was just
recreate the protocol from natalya's
study that we looked at initially mainly
just to make sure that our
processing pipeline was working as
intended we were getting the results
that we were expecting so just as a
reminder this paradigm had first
a
fixation cross appear for a period of
one second
a blank screen for two seconds an image
would pop up for four seconds and the
participant would be asked to just
attend to the stimulus and focus on the
features of it
we had two different classes of images
of a flower and a hammer so it was
always the same flower always the same
hammer throughout the experiment just in
a random order
so once they focused on that for four
seconds the image would disappear and
they'd be asked to imagine that stimulus
that they just saw
there'd be a rest period for four
seconds a blank screen and that would
repeat
so i recorded a single session that was
divided into four runs
and i had 40 trials of hammer images 40
trials of flower images
and this was about like a little under
30 minutes worth of data collection
total
so further moving on to the results from
this experiment
the first thing that we wanted to look
at was a classifier built off of the
observation periods so the objective
here was to perform a two-class
classification of when they were looking
at a flower versus when they were
looking at a tool
so some of the pre-processing steps that
i took first i extracted the
oc01 and o2 channels so these were the
ones directly over the primary visual
cortex in the back of the head
i re-referenced those channels to the
average of the tp9 and tp10 electrodes
so those are the two directly behind the
ears on the mastoids
the data was filtered with the 1 to 40
hertz bandpass filter
and a notch at 60 hertz to remove the
power line noise
and
i e-pocked the windows
so if you remember i had around four
seconds
during the observation period i kind of
narrowed that down to a total of 3.5
seconds of data and split that up into
window sizes of 1.75 seconds with the 50
overlap so they gave us like three
windows for each trial
and then i have for my features i used
the full 1 to 40 hertz power spectrum
i used a linear support vector machine
classifier and cross validated it using
a leave one run out cross validation
so for the results of this visual
observation classifier it was pretty
good we were getting around 63 accuracy
so it was relatively good at classifying
whether they were looking at a flower
versus a hammer and our accuracy of 63
was pretty close to what natalya was
getting at 61 so it looked like
everything was working as intended there
so moving on to the visual imagery
classifier
so the objective here was to perform a
two-class classification of when they
were imagining that flower stimulus and
imagining the tool stimulus
so similar processing steps of
extracting the
oz012 channels in the back of the head
re-referencing them to the ones behind
the ears except now we're filtering the
data with the larger frequency band so
with the observation periods we use 1 to
40 hertz but the visual imagery it seems
like
the higher gamma range contains a little
bit more information about imagery
periods
so we bump that
filter up to 1 to 125 hertz
with a notch at 60 and 120 hertz to
remove power line noise and it's
harmonic
and use the same e-box size and our
features here were the full power
spectrum in the one to 100 hertz range
and use the same
svm classifier to leave one run out
and that's for accuracy here
unfortunately we were still getting
around chance level accuracy we weren't
able to
fully identify if they were looking at
or imagining a flower or a hammer
however this was
in line with what natanie was getting in
her experiment as well
so the next thing that we looked at was
an observation period versus risk
classifier so the objective here was two
class classification of
rest versus observation periods
so most of it was the same except for
we combined all the observation trials
into a single label
so this seemed to work pretty well we
were able to pretty accurately predict
uh whether you know they're resting
versus looking at an image so around
like 77 and a half percent where natalie
was getting 75 so everything was
going as we were expecting there
and then we looked at an imagery versus
rest classifier so the same kind of
thing combining all the imagery trials
into a single label and just trying to
classify
if they're resting versus imagining a
picture
and this actually worked really well
like we were able to get 81 accuracy
here where she was getting 77 so that
was functioning as we intended as well
so this was a pretty interesting result
how you know we weren't able to
differentiate you know within like the
imagery period we couldn't really tell
if they were looking or thinking about a
flower or a hammer but we could tell
that they were trying to perform visual
imagery and when they were resting
so the next thing that i wanted to look
at was to try to evaluate this
performance with different image stimuli
so it was kind of interesting that we
were able to
differentiate between those categories
during the observation period but not
during the imagery period
and one reason for this that i might
have
that i started to kind of notice that
might help explain this was that
you know the flower that we were using
was a pretty large white flower and the
hammer was like a smaller darker hammer
so maybe during our observation periods
we were really classifying like a bright
stimulus versus a dim stimulus and that
might be why we weren't getting any uh
information during the imagery periods
so to test out this i tried you know
adding a few more pictures of flowers
throughout the experiment
keeping the same general
size but having slightly different
colors or different shapes
and then for the hammers you know use
the same like size hammers but maybe at
different orientations and slightly
different colors
so interestingly enough here first with
the visual observation classifier doing
all the same pre-processing and
classification stages steps as before
our classification accuracy dropped down
to chance level so before we were you
know around 60 percent now we're down to
chance so we weren't able to identify if
they were looking at flower versus a
hammer
and same thing kind of with the visual
imagery classifier again we were still
around chance level it seemed to kind of
bump up a little bit like maybe we had a
little bit better luck with the flower
category but still our overall accuracy
was mostly around chance
then for the classifier for the
observation period versus rest periods
we saw
still a buck chance accuracy
had a slight drop here but we're still
getting around 69 percent we're before
we were like around 75
and then for the imagery versus risk
classifier we saw a pretty big drop here
i think before our accuracy was like 81
now we're down to like 61.5
so the next experiment that i tried was
um
including different image stimuli of a
face versus scene and this was just to
see if we could
try something different to help boost
their classification during the imagery
periods
so the idea of using a face in the scene
this is a pretty
common image stimulus to use in a lot of
visual neuroscience applications so
there's multiple sites throughout the
occipital and temporal regions in the
brain that seem to respond pretty
selectively to faces and scene images
so perhaps the most well-known and
well-studied one is the
areas in the ventral temporal cortex the
fusiform face area and the para
hippocampal place area
but there's also areas throughout like
different areas of the occipital regions
that seem to respond more maximally to
either faces or scenes i want to be
careful with saying that that you know
it's not like the brain is really
compartmentalized as like you know this
areas faces the serious scenes this
area's hammers like it's not exactly
like that you know these activity
patterns are pretty dispersed throughout
the visual network but it does seem
particularly for faces and scenes like
there are some regions that are more
maximally responsive to each one so
perhaps this might give us a little bit
better results
and so i also
study showing that you know face and
seeing images have also shown to be
effective in visual imagery eeg bcis
so it's a pretty early study from 2011
where they tried to do a three-class
classification of
resting versus face versus scene imagery
and they're able to achieve around 56
classification accuracy so pretty good
above chance accuracy there
so using these space and scene stimuli
first off with the visual observation
classifier
performing similar
pre-processing steps and everything our
accuracy was still right around like 60
like we were seeing before so everything
stayed pretty good there
and then for our visual imagery
classifier here's where we saw the
biggest benefit so we're before we were
right around chance level
now using like all the electro channels
re-referencing them to the ones behind
the ears doing the same sort of
filtering
we're now getting like 64 accuracy so
we're able to differentiate when they
were thinking about the person's face
versus thinking about the scene pretty
well
so one other thing that i tested here
was getting a few extra sessions of this
experimental paradigm so i
had three sessions total of this visual
imagery classifier
i used the same pre-processing sets for
all of them you know using all the
channels except the ones behind the ears
that i were using to re-reference
doing the same 100 to 125 hertz band
pass filter
uh same epoch sizes 100 hertz power
spectrum for features
and so we're seeing for first off the
face versus scene imagery uh from
sessions one to three it looks like
we're pretty consistently around sixty
percent
what was really cool about this data is
when i tried to do like a between
session classification so
like test are training my classifier on
say sessions one and session two and
testing it on like a new session data
that it hasn't seen
we're still able to get like 60
classification accuracy which is pretty
cool because most of the time with eeg
applications it's kind of hard to
transfer data from one session to the
other
then even for the rest versus imagery
periods
uh
from sessions one to three it looks like
our classification accuracy you know
increased a little bit starting around
like 60 up to a little above seventy
percent
and the between subject classification
accuracy here i was still pretty high
around sixty five percent so training on
two sessions and testing on a left out
one
so the last thing that i tried here was
you know splitting apart that
rest and imagery periods into its
individual categories so doing a
three-way classification of
rest versus face versus scene
so from sessions one to three it was all
performing pretty consistently above
chance around fifty percent and even
from our between subject or between
session classifier of you know training
on two testing on a third was still
giving us pretty high around fifty 50
classification accuracy
so next thing that we tried here was an
online real-time vci application so you
know having the participants you know
imagining one of these stimuli and then
giving them feedback directly from the
classification output to see how it was
working
so in this experiment the first two runs
were like exactly from the training ones
you know we had the fixation cross blank
screen an observation period for four
seconds where it was looking at either a
face or a scene image
they performed imagery for four seconds
a rest period for four seconds and then
a blank screen for two seconds
then in the last two runs
it was a little bit different so during
the observation periods instead of just
having the two image categories they
could also be queued to rest during the
imagery period
and then instead of a rest period at the
end they were actually provided feedback
directly from the classifier's output of
you know what it predicted they were
thinking about during the imagery period
so as for the results from this
experiment this the objective here was
the three glass classification of face
and scene imagery versus resting state
i the pre-processing steps were all the
same as before you know using all the
channels except the ones behind the ears
re-referencing them to those mastoid
electrodes
the same higher filter band the same
e-box size
then for the training data i used the
three previous training sessions as
before plus the additional two runs from
the current session to kind of
initialize the classifier
and it seems like our accuracy was still
pretty high like right above our right
around where we were getting before with
50 you know we just saw a slight drop
and looked like we were getting pretty
good accuracy at identifying the rest
periods and identifying when they were
thinking of a face
there was a slight problem with the
scene
images it seemed like
that was more around chance levels
getting confused with the faces quite a
bit but it still seemed pretty
consistent of you know identifying
visual imagery was occurring and resting
was occurring
so the last thing that i want to show
you here is just a demo of this
real-time pci experiment so
first two runs of this is like a demo of
the initial
training sessions
so
this would be like what happened in the
first three training runs in the first
two runs of the
experimental session
so in each run
the person would first see the fixation
cross
and observation image here so in this
case a face image
then it would have the imagery period
for four seconds where they're just
trying to imagine that image and then a
resting period and that would just
repeat
observation
imagery
and then rest
so next moving on to the like real time
feedback stages so those final two runs
of the experiment
so in this um they're seeing the
observation queue of like a face in this
trial
performing imagery like trying to
remember the features that face and then
you see the classifier's output like in
this case they got the prediction right
so the next trial starts we see the
fixation cross this time we're queued to
rest during the imagery period
so we're just trying to keep our mind
blank during this stage
and the classifier predicts risk so i
got it right that time again
new trial starts
this time is rest again
resting
and then the feedback
and a new trial starts
this time it's a scene image pops up so
we're focusing on the scene image
and then trying to imagine that picture
that we just saw
and then for the feedback in this case
it got it wrong it predicted as a face
instead of a scene
so moving on to just like a conclusions
a summary of everything that we've seen
so the objective of this experiment was
to create a brain computer interface
using a visual imagery control paradigm
for the offline results that we saw we
were able to achieve above chance
classification accuracy when using
imagery of faces and scenes so around
like 62 percent class of classification
accuracy between these two
for the we also saw that the visual
imagery was pretty stable across
sessions so we had 50
balanced accuracy of rest versus face
versus scene between those three
sessions
so one thing i forgot to mention before
was that during these three class
classification on the offline stages
here i was using balanced accuracy
instead of just the standard
classification accuracy is because our
um our data sets were a little bit
unbalanced in this case because we had
you know 40 trials of faces 40 trials of
scenes but there was a rest period each
trial so there's twice as many rest as
each of those categories
so this balance measure just kind of
helps to create a little bit less biased
classification score where instead of
you know just judging how many totally
got right and how many totally got wrong
it finds the classification accuracy
per category and then averages them
together so it helped out for here
because you know we're our classifier
was actually pretty good at identifying
the rest periods uh so if we use just
standard classification accuracy it
would have looked like a lot higher
score than it actually was
and then on to our online results we saw
that we were able to achieve similar
performance in our real-time vci around
classification in this three-way
of
rest versus faced and scene imagery
some of the limitations of the study and
potential areas for future work is that
you know due to limitations of you know
me having to work home alone i was the
only participant in the study so
definitely need more data for more
people to fully validate the conclusions
in this experiment
i think it would also be beneficial to
try to collect some more data perhaps
from like a wet electro cap to improve
the data quality so like i mentioned
before with these dry electrodes it can
be a little bit more susceptible to
noise and we're also kind of limited on
the amount of data that we can collect
so like we were only collecting a little
less than 30 minutes of data so perhaps
getting a little bit more each session
would help our accuracy a bit more
and then finally i just like to
thank my
mentor this summer yvonne
thank you so much for all the feedback
and advice throughout the summer
i couldn't have asked for a better
mentor
thank you to the entire bci team
your feedback and all the support and
help during our meetings was very
valuable for getting the project to
where it's at right now
thanks david for helping me get all the
technical side of stuff worked out at
the beginning and thank you demetra for
organizing a great morale event for us
thank you to all of the all my fellow
research interns in the audio and
acoustics groups it was great working
with you all this summer
and getting to know you all a little bit
and i wish you all the best and special
thanks to natalia for you know meeting
with me and giving me some feedback and
advice on this project
and thanks to all the research intern
program coordinators who organized some
fun events for us this summer to kind of
give us a break from some stressful work
times and uh thank you all for coming to
my talk and listening to me and i'd be
happy to answer any questions you might
have
thank you justin dear colleagues the
floor is open for questions
oh please go ahead
hey
they just did great stuff um
just a i guess an experimental question
in terms of how you uh like do the train
test split
uh so with the 50 overlap you kind of
have to be a little careful
in terms of making sure your training
data isn't actually leaking into the
test data and so were you
kind of like breaking down each like
three like three or four second epic
into
train tests and then doing the overlap
or how exactly did you handle that that
issue
yeah so my experiment was like the full
experimental session was divided into
four runs so it allowed you to get like
a little break between each rung so when
i was actually you know testing the data
like pulling out the data for training
and testing
all the training data came from three
runs and then the testing was from a
left out one so there was no leaking of
you know those
windows maybe overlapping in the trial
like it was completely different trials
that was being tested on
great right thanks
any more questions
i have a quick question
uh justin in the real time
demo that you showed us one of the you
had two paradigms and the second
paradigm actually had a real-time
feedback
is that um something you're planning to
use in the future or have you actually
used it already
um
for learning during the training session
yeah so during the real time um the
paradigm was set up where like you know
the first two runs were like the same as
the training this was just to get some
additional training data to help
initialize our classifier i initially
tried like you know fully training the
classifier from previous runs that it
hadn't seen before and just doing fully
online feedback but without like giving
it a little bit of data from the current
session it didn't perform as well like
it's i think around like 38 39 accurate
but increase but adding a little bit of
training data from the current session
boosted that up to around like 48
so i did actually have fully online um
vci
and
accuracy you can see the predictions
here it was around 47
got it
is there so for the feedback that you're
showing to the participant what is the
benefit either to the participant or to
you are you recording the reaction to
that feedback and you may use that as an
additional um
signal
yeah at the moment right now i wasn't
doing anything with the data during the
actual feedback periods but one thing
that you know we were kind of initially
planning to do at the beginning of this
was creating an adaptive pci to where
you know you can use the data from that
feedback period and see like you know if
you see like
maybe a an error related potential in
that in their brain waves during that
feedback period we could see that you
know the classifier got it wrong and we
could try to you know
more finely tune our classification
between that but as for right now i
wasn't
using any of the feedback data
got it thank you
thank you
more questions
well some people think about a potential
question justin
one of the most interesting findings
here is the
independence of the classifier from
session to session
we usually see a drastic difference
and
reduction in the accuracy
when we have a classifier training on
one session and try to use it in the
next session
how would you explain the fact that you
can train a classifier on
two sessions and
use it on the third without substantial
reduction in the accuracy
yeah that's a great question i mean yeah
a lot of times with these you know eeg
applications you really do see a pretty
drastic drop between the sessions i mean
this could be from many reasons of like
you know fatigue during the session or
even just the electrodes being at
slightly different positions so it was
pretty cool that you know in my
data set that i had right here i wasn't
seeing any drop between that and
honestly i'm not really sure exactly why
uh we weren't seeing a huge drop here um
i mean definitely to make sure that
there isn't a drop with visual imagery
we definitely need to try to test this
out on some different participants
instead of just myself get some more
data to actually validate this but
yeah
thank you uh more questions dear
colleagues
oh come on go ahead
um hello uh can you hear me
yes he came for you
hi um a great talk i really enjoyed it
um i was wondering if um there's any
um thoughts about sort of analyzing the
features that might be
allowing for the separability in the
different classes maybe like looking at
the different power bands and what
actual features will be uh
contributing to the separability
yeah so
what i was doing right now like what i
saw with a lot of the
um other kind of similar
visual imagery bcis it seemed like using
uh features from the frequency spectrum
particularly the high gamma
spectrum of brain activity seem to carry
the most relevant uh information from
visual imagery however that one study
that i talked about that had like you
know the 13 different classes that had
40 accuracy
they had a little bit more advanced uh
feature selection they were using like
common spatial patterns so definitely
there could be some more work on this
side to see if you know using some
different types of features could help
improve her accuracy some more right now
you know just kind of starting with
a little bit simpler uh just frequency
spectrums and
seeing how that worked
good great question thank you
more questions
okay i just i'm gonna wait for my turn
if someone else has a question um
so
justin you in this project you have been
both the principal investigator of the
study but also the participant
and
typically
what the one wants or is expects is kind
of conflicting with what the other
side of of this
study
um
the other side of the of the coin i
suppose
one one of the issues you mentioned is
that
for example as a private investigator
you you wish you could have more data
recorded
but as a participant
at times it may get a little bit painful
so
you couldn't leave the device
on on your head for
long periods at a time is there anything
else that you may have observed from
these two sides of of this project
regarding the stimuli perhaps
improvements that could come
because you've been taking that
experiment yourself that study yourself
as a participant
yeah so
that's a great question some of the
things that i noticed about this
experiment um i mean first off
you know it did seem that we saw some
improvements like when we were you know
adding that additional data from other
sessions so it does seem like
you know we are a little bit limited
just by the amount of data that i was
able to collect from myself each session
uh one other thing that i noticed that i
didn't really talk about
in these slides one of the things that i
tried to you know the very start of the
summer
was
having three different classes of you
know like face images scene images and
then having like an object category like
showing like hammers and tools and
things like that
someone uh interesting aspect that i
if i had more time to kind of dive into
that more is you know trying to add some
additional categories in here
because even with those three different
imagery categories you know some of our
results were actually looking pretty
positive there uh in this i was actually
able to get two different participants
in that myself and my wife participated
in that and we were both around like 40
to 45 percent between
all the three of those categories so it
did look like we were still able to
get a pretty good above chance
classifier between three different image
categories instead of just two is here
and i wish i could have gotten some more
data but yeah after my wife tried it the
first time and realized how painful it
was she refused to do any more of it so
all right
that's interesting yeah thank you um
yeah it's a big struggle uh trying to
get um participants especially when
you're doing a virtual internship um or
working virtually
um
yeah
uh justin we have a question in the chat
see if i can pull that up
or harvey if you prefer to
just read it
okay i can see it do you have any ideas
for doing this at home at scale having
people help out
being shipped equipment giving you
experiments worked from home it's both
the investigating subject
um
so yeah carrying out this experiment
you know
at home like if we were trying to you
know ship people equipment i think that
would be kind of difficult
uh sharing equipment around um you know
the g caps they are
relatively inexpensive but they're still
not super cheap to send around to people
and you know it'd be hard to rely on
people having equipment like that at
home so yeah working from home is
definitely a challenge with
experiments like these that do require
specialized equipment it kind of
requires a bit of uh lab
space to do the same
it is actually not that
easy simply put
not everybody has the skills to put
properly the
eg cap and to make it to work and to get
the data
we have didn't done in the bci team in
microsoft research the opposite thing
when we have the equipment installed in
a lab
and members of the bci team go and
one per day take turns to put the
equipment and to record the data this is
how we did
the data collection for one of our
studies
but those are
people members of the bci team with
certain
skills and
ability to work with the equipment
unless the equipment is enormously
simple
to use
that could be a problem
more questions dear colleagues
yeah there's quite a bit to check in you
know making sure each of the electrodes
have proper placements and getting a
proper reading like having the full
contact with the scalp and then just
getting all the programs set up like i
have four different programs running at
the same time you know collecting the
data transmitting it processing it
presenting the stimulus so it
would be a little bit hard to set up if
you're not fully experienced in it
okay more more questions dear colleagues
more questions once
more questions too
okay i
say we thank justin for his talk
thank you justin
thank you
thank you all
and thank you everybody for coming to
this meeting
uh
if there are no more questions
i would say
this stock is our
thank you again for
coming to the final talk of justin
kellmark's intern in audio and acoustics
research group
let me stop the recording
and how to do that